boston consulting group is hewing the
meme stock company gamestop for 30
million us dollar and unpaid consulting
fees wow what's going on here i can
promise you this whole story is complete
craziness this is what i want to talk
about with you today so welcome here on
another coffee break here on my channel
where i try to help you become
successful in the first years of your
career the reason i want to talk about
the story is that first i think it's
quite juicy it's quite interesting what
is happening here but second it's also
very insightful to better understand how
big consulting firms like boston
consulting group actually work and what
type of projects they do for their
clients and so for this video now i did
some firm learning detective work for
you because i got hold on some chord
documents the boston consulting group
filed to sue gamestop and these chord
documents are quite interesting indeed
lots of very juicy details on what
they're actually doing for gamestop so
let's look into them in a moment before
that let me just read out this statement
that now gamestop gave to financial
times as a response to what bcg is doing
and gamestop is saying
we do not believe it is in our
stockholders best interests to pay the
tens of millions of dollars sought by
boston consulting group especially given
their seemingly meager impact on the
company's bottom line we will fight the
suit and are proud that gamestop no
longer utilizes the likes of bcg for any
services ah that's really heavy tobacco
here i just want to make it really clear
that of course all of this document here
is written from the perspective of
boston consulting group so i have of
course no insider knowledge into any of
this at all i have no idea whether one
boston consulting group is claiming is
alleging here in the document is true or
not but let's go into it nevertheless so
these are the court filings that are
found as you can see this is with boston
consulting group as a plaintiff and
gamestop corporation as a defendant and
this was apparently filed on the 22nd of
march obviously i'm no legal
professionals of anything i say from
legal perspectives not maybe accurate
just let me know in the comments happy
to learn from you to just understand
this better what i want to do now is
really go over this with you and already
read this in advance and just provided
some highlights some yellow highlights
of the parts i feel like are most
relevant and most interesting so let's
look into it so what does bcg want well
they are claiming that there is from
gamestop side bad face refuel to pay
fees out to bcg right another describing
a bit the situation of the company so
here by 2019 games that was on live
support really not doing well was
reporting a net operating loss of almost
800 million dollar of 2018 and was one
of the most heavily shorted stocks
relative to its float so this is maybe
what some of you know if you follow the
whole gamestop story last year how it
became a meme stock and so from all of
this gamestop then engaged bcg in 2019
to evaluate its operations and develop
solutions that would enable a corporate
transformation and here apparently there
was a target set of generating an
additional 200 million or more in profit
per year going forward the bcg wanted to
deliver to the client and the idea of
course why it might make sense for a
company to pay even a fee of let's say
30 million us dollar which is now what
they are fighting here apparently in
court about is that of course if you are
able to improve profits of course this
is not a one-off right but this would be
on a recurring basis so if you are able
to increase the profit by 200 million
dollar on a recurring basis it's quite
easy to justify the business case of
paying as a one-off right 30 million
dollar in consulting fees that's of
course a big difference the fees are
only a one-off but the profits the
savings are recurring which is why the
business case often then does make sense
bcg provided support to gamestop in
connection with 10 different work
streams spread across a broad range of
business areas and opportunities i think
this is now a bit more interesting also
going into how consulting firms work so
if you are a consulting firm and you set
up such a big transformation program
often you divide it into different
pieces and the different names for that
here workstream is one of them other
firms sometimes also like to call it
modules 10 different workstreams is
quite a significant transformation
program that's really big right i mean
imagine managing 10 big independent
topics next to each other on smaller
programs sometimes it's the case that
it's only one project team working on it
and then maybe that's the project lead
and then two three four five associates
and then each of the associates is
responsible for one of the work streams
but in a larger program and i would
assume i don't know of course but i
would assume that this is what happened
here often each individual work stream
is being worked on by an independent
project team or at least the most
important work streams are being worked
on by independent project teams and then
there's also one project team on top of
all of it coordinating it all serving as
a pmo is often called project management
office then it also goes on saying that
bcg would be compensated on the greater
of a fixed fee or a variable fee based
upon projected
profit improvements so the fee was not
predetermined or kept
and this i think also quite something
noteworthy because sometimes there's
this prejudice right against consultants
where people say that oh you know the
consultants they just create these these
fancy strategies and then they get a
fixed fee for that and then just leave
and so the fear is not really success
based but that's not always the case
rather often actually consulting firms
do have some performance components in
the fees and this is here now really
also describing how this works right and
they now will start together of course
with the client start ideating creating
all types of measures all types ideas
for initiatives then could potentially
lead to profit improvements and then
often you say oh how this works is often
then the consulting firm comes in and
says well okay let's do here a
performance-based program as soon as we
have a measure where your controller
where dear client where your controller
says that yes this measure is viable
then i get paid for that right and this
is this idea of projections of
anticipated profit improvements and so
now here it goes on explaining why this
was the type of agreement that was made
so to protect bcg
from additional factors such as game
stops execution risk right this of
course where you could say now that
these types of agreements may be
sometimes a little bit sneaky because
it's very easy right to come up with an
idea and have a controller say you know
there's a business case behind it or
maybe an executive decision to them
bring in life but then often of course
in the execution is where many of these
things go wrong of course there is them
and often these measures fail right and
are not really being executed rightfully
and this of course here is where bcd
says well that's not my problem that's
your problem right if you are not able
to execute them i will still get paid
and so now you can argue whether that's
fair or not but at least i think it's
fair to say that of course you're two
very competent actors we're negotiating
this and we're agreeing that this is
fine and then this would the parties
agreed in the end but i think also if
you if you read a statement like the
statement that just quoted you from
gamestop in the beginning where they
were saying that actually the work did
not really lead to profit improvements
in the end the cities was games that was
was claiming in the statement there you
see the problem with agreements like
that right because again here pcg now
wants to get paid based on any
projections and our games of course are
saying well thank you for these
projections but in the end these things
didn't realize didn't realize in the
bottom line this seems to be the main
conflict or this part of the conflict
that these parties are having just me
judging based on all the statements here
right i think this is quite interesting
because here in the filings bcg talks
about the work streams that they were
working on right so i think this is an
insight that probably don't get that off
from other content and you can see that
here there are 10 work streams going on
i just highlighted some yellow ones some
very typical ones for free just to stop
and also also read the text and all the
other ones
so here first org efficiency and
effectiveness to unlock both costs and
operational improvement through a
combination of organizational levers
improved spans of control and more
effective reporting structures
redesigning roads and responsibilities
among others and i mean frankly this
usually is just you know nice speak for
saying they want to cut cost and the
overhead of gamestop so if you read this
right so improved spans of control means
that one manager is now responsible
potentially for more people than before
and by that you might be able to take
out some middle management roles and
similar things of course is when you
talk about redesigned roads and
responsibilities among others category
performance improvements so here it
looks like they're looking into just
different business areas working
together with the vendors to potentially
release additional cost improvements
here getting better prices negotiating
with them so these are often procurement
related initiatives indirect procurement
this of course also in procurement
initiative so usually you think about
direct procurement in indirect
procurement so direct procurement is
everything that goes into the product so
the manufacturing context that might be
for instance the the steel that you use
to really build the products or here in
such a retail component of course that
would be the merchandise that the
purchase in indirect procurement are all
the other cost positions that you have
with the exception of personnel right so
not personnel but all the other cost
positions that are not really directly
related to the product so this could be
your utilities this could be your rent
the rent that you pay global enterprise
these are often global footprint
decisions for the company right so which
markets am i active in how is my
organization distributed where do i have
offices is there any potential maybe
just to close down complete countries
where i'm just losing money not making
any profit at all maybe just to close
down some production facilities if i
have any close down maybe some
headquarters administrative officers
sales officers that i have and here
let's look how just additional
explanations on how this whole variable
compensation component was supposed to
be built and was supposed to be paid and
they were supposed to hold some regular
sessions together with the gamestop team
and the bcg team where the idea was that
they look together at all these numbers
it's all these facts all these
initiatives that they created and then
they just wanted to ideally form a joint
opinion know what the status is and then
based on this view then of course also
proceed with all the invoicing and they
called you these meetings thermometer
meetings i think that's also an
interesting name and all these projected
profits were supposed to be calculated
against agreed upon baselines not actual
profits realized this whole idea of
building baselines is also an important
one because this is often also
especially the beginning of these
transformation programs something that
at least the one associate will often be
concerned with and here the idea really
is this this person often just tries to
develop different scenarios where so
tries to develop a scenario what would
happen if nothing would happen right so
if no measure would be taken if just
business continues as usual how does
maybe the situation of the company look
like in one year from now and this is
then the baseline and then against this
baseline you the measure or the
financial improvements and then of
course based on that you can also
develop scenarios so based on the effect
of all the measures sometimes of course
the baselines are not constant but
deteriorating right so imagine a company
where profits were down year over year
over a year of course then this baseline
will go into the negative for the next
year right so what you will say is that
if we do nothing next year profits will
be let's say just a random number 100
million less than last year right and
now of course any profit improvement you
can calculate on top of this baseline
but what this also means is that even
though if you have or if you understand
or realize 100 million in initiatives
and profit improvement initiatives this
would just leave the company's bottom
line just with no change right just with
a zero data compared to the last year
because you're not necessarily measuring
against the last year but you're
measuring against the deteriorating
baseline of course this isn't something
that maybe not always managers really
realize if they put this together with
with the help of these conducting firms
and then of course they expect big jumps
big increases in profit and then of
course you'll often have these difficult
situations where the consulting firm is
claiming oh but are you know realized
like
all these great profit improvements but
then the company is just looking at the
bottom line comparing one ear with the
other seeing there's actually no change
at all and then just wondering what
exactly happened here right why the work
of the conductance was worthless of
course i think this logic of measuring
against the baseline is not wrong but of
course not always easy to communicate in
these dispute type of situations so you
can see that you know what does i mean
what is bcg claiming that gamestop
failed and refused to pay bcg that if
they paid they they paid late that uh
here the cfo demanded all types of
unsupported reductions to bcg fees
that they just ceased to attend these
thermometer meetings so i mean that's of
course also a strategy if you just don't
attend these meetings anymore then bcg
doesn't have any basis of going to you
and trying to charge you for these cost
improvements that's apparently what they
try to do here at least this is what bcg
claims again no idea of course whether
this is correct or not and here they're
just saying you know unpaid fees of
approximately 30 millions this is what
they want to have and then interestingly
also saying the exact amount of the
variable fees owned to bcg is
undetermined at this time due to
gamestop's refusal to hold thermometer
meetings or otherwise furnish the data
necessary to determine certain profit
improvements that's exactly the problem
right so if you just stop attending this
meeting then of course you don't have
any issues here so that's really the
gist of what's happening here i must say
when i read all this i did find this to
be quite interesting i hope you feel the
very same way so now let me know in the
comments it's all of this surprising to
you did you already know that this is
how these firms operate as always if you
took any value out of this video at all
please hit the like button for the
youtube algorithm and also subscribe to
set up the date on all my content my
name is heinrich herrelly's weekly
videos here on my channel big big thanks
to all the members of from learning for
your support much appreciated see you
again next week until then all the best
to you and bye